[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a comedy sci-fi film called
the world sinks except japan
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
two japanese men goto and koga are in a
bar after a long day at work they make
fun of an american performer singing in
a horrible japanese accent recently
japan has been flooded with foreigners
from around the world moving into the
country the president of america is
sitting beside the two in the bar
hearing them make fun of his people the
politician interrupts their conversation
he claims that japanese people should be
patient with the american immigrants
because they are trying their best to
learn the language goto disagrees
because language is not the only issue
he claims that america has the highest
crime rate in the world humiliated by
the civilians the president insults the
entire country of japan but stops when
the president of japan arrives at the
club it turns out that all the
presidents and higher officials of the
world are in this club a flashback shows
us goto with his american wife catherine
the two are a happy couple and living in
tokyo goto narrates that this night when
he was enjoying his time with his wife
was a horrible one for the rest of the
world the movement of the tectonic
plates under the earth caused massive
earthquakes and tsunamis at first the
entire continent of america sank
underwater and only the rich managed to
escape drowning in the ocean in a
japanese broadcasting company the news
spreads like wildfire making everyone
panic the president of america presents
his final statement on the matter
through a live broadcast on a plane he
asks the citizens to keep calm because
the neighboring nations will help them
in time of need as he talks a
half-dressed woman serves him a drink
but the president seems to ignore that
while the country is sinking he sings a
song about america being the greatest
nation in the world
the japanese officials watched the live
show in awe they also find out that he
is heading to a base in okinawa japan
they are ready to take in american
refugees as a gesture of friendship goto
also works in the same office and is
arguing with his wife on the phone she
wants to return to america because she
is worried about her family in texas
little does she know the mass of land
that was once texas is now under the
ocean at the house of parliament
professor tato koro tells the president
about a mantle plume under the surface
of the earth that still has energy and
is ready to erupt he begins explaining
everything about the mantle but doesn't
get to the point when the president asks
him what is going to happen next he
falls asleep and has to be woken up
after a long chat he is about to reveal
the conclusion but at the same time
their meeting is interrupted somewhere
else oscar-winning actor jerry cruising
and his actress girlfriend elizabeth
land in japan although their entire
country has drowned they seem to be
excited about their new life jerry
believes that since he is world famous
the japanese film industry will offer
him millions to be in their movie
elizabeth is just as excited so much so
that she can't help but call japanese
people racial slurs they are interviewed
by the reporters about the situation in
america before they left jerry pretends
to be sad but swiftly changes the
subject to his oscar koga is one of the
reporters interviewing them he asks
jerry to be in a japanese drama his
broadcasting company is shooting next
month the actor happily agrees to be in
the show in the following scene goto
returns home to catherine who is worried
about her family in america he assures
her they are okay since millions of
people have fled to different parts of
asia and europe as refugees meanwhile
koga also reaches home to his wife they
have dinner together while talking about
the price of food skyrocketing after
imports from the us ended koga excitedly
tells her about his meeting with jerry
they assume that because of the actors
japanese cinema will be as successful as
hollywood for the first few weeks
americans are welcomed to japan
wholeheartedly people donate to american
refugee charities and aid them as much
as possible one day a man holding bowls
of chinese noodles falls off a bicycle
as the dish drops into a ditch the
entire nation of china sinks under the
ocean similarly a woman drops a baguette
in the ditch causing france and the
entirety of europe to sink eventually
all countries sink underwater leaving
japan as the only land mass on earth
almost 90 percent of the population of
earth die because of the impact
in addition the population of japan
increases at an exponential rate it is
now a few years later after japan became
the sole country in the world the
americans living in japan have gone
completely broke famous american actors
do tricks for japanese businessmen for
money the korean and chinese presidents
turn into minions of the japanese
president so he would allow their
refugees more freedom somewhere else the
professor tells his students that the
tectonic plates still have some energy
left which is very soon going to do
something big as usual he explains all
the unnecessary details passionately but
forgets to get to the conclusion instead
he dances away from the class leaving
his students wondering one day on his
way to work goto realizes that his
country has more foreigners than its own
people he is on a train with hundreds of
people and not one japanese person in
sight he tries to move around the
crowded place and locks eyes with a
japanese man both of them look at each
other knowingly but can do nothing about
the situation in addition the japanese
yen becomes the strongest currency
making any other currency in the world
worth pennies as the prices of food hike
the refugees resort to begging stealing
and looting jerry stars in a high budget
japanese movie people had thought that
the rise in american population would
make the movie a hit but they soon
realized that the target audience cannot
even afford a tv jerry loses his job
along with elizabeth they hand their
landlord bundles of us dollars but
because of inflation it is still not
enough eventually the once oscar-winning
actors go homeless
in the meantime the japanese grow richer
in comparison to most of the population
koga and his wife are shown eating
different delicacies like whale and
tiger mead his wife informs him that she
is pregnant the couple is overjoyed by
the good news mostly because the birth
of the child will bring one more
japanese into the country the following
day on his way to work koga sees
elizabeth and takes her out for lunch
she appears to be starving as she
devours her food and eats from his plate
as well the actress complains about not
getting any jobs and going homeless to
make her feel better koga claims that he
will find her a job no matter what
however he knows that no director wants
to cast americans in their movies after
the disaster with jerry's last film
somewhere else the professor is enjoying
his time with foreign women who have
agreed to be his mistresses for money
one of his students is waiting for him
to explain the functioning of the
tectonic plates as the man flirts with
the women the professor explains his
theory using sexual examples but stops
before coming to a conclusion yet again
when asked about his wife he gets mad
and chases the student away meanwhile
elizabeth also turns into a prostitute
to earn money she charges extra money
because of her status but men do not
mind paying however her relationship
with jerry deteriorates because of her
new profession goto's wife catherine is
furious at the japanese government for
not providing her people with proper
facilities since goto doesn't care about
the foreign policies she gets mad at him
as well on top of that he suggests they
hire foreign maids since they are
affordable and make you look rich
catherine is strictly against the idea
but goto plans to do it nonetheless the
actor jerry on the other hand is living
in the streets with the other refugees
when elizabeth returns home late from
work he asks her where she was she
bluntly claims that she was with a
customer she even suggests he joined the
business asking him to be more
productive since he does nothing all day
they get into a massive argument during
which elizabeth breaks his oscar award
that he loved more than his life the two
break up after the fight when the crime
rate increases the president of japan
appoints the defense general as the head
of an anti-refugee organization several
soldiers are then sent out to look for
illegal refugees and leave them in the
middle of the ocean in the name of
deporting them those who do not follow
the law or adjust to japan's way of
living will also be deported the main
aim of the government is to throw out as
many foreigners as possible so they will
not consider rechecking the documents
even if a person is falsely reported to
be an illegal immigrant the presidents
of the other nations know this hence
they try to stop the bill but the
japanese president is adamant about his
decision he even makes the other
presidents dance to a kid's song about
japan's greatness soon several illegal
immigrants are caught they start to
complain against each other after the
government offers rice cakes to those
who inform them of the illegal people
several innocent and legal ones are also
deported because of the rule jerry has
started to work for a brothel for money
one day catherine sees him on the
sidewalk and recognizes him as her
childhood celebrity crush at first jerry
thinks she is making fun of him like
everyone else after he finds out that
she is genuinely happy to see him he
opens up to her about his situation the
policemen find it suspicious and ask
catherine for identification when they
see she is a japanese man's wife they
let her go catherine hands jerry the
groceries she had just bought when he
says he has nothing to eat when goto
returns home that day he is welcomed by
his foreign maids they help him change
into pajamas and even go to the bathroom
with him in case he needs something
since catherine didn't shop for
tonight's dinner they couldn't cook
anything a furious goto asks his wife
why she didn't buy food like she was
supposed to the couple gets into an
argument which escalates when goto slaps
catherine she storms out of the house
saying that she is leaving him the
following day goto happens to see her on
his way to work she is arguing with the
deportation police who are trying to
take jerry away goto interferes and asks
her why she is trying to save a stranger
catherine then admits that she is in
love with jerry and wants to go with him
even if it means ending up in the ocean
her husband is shocked but he can do
nothing to change her mind in a bar the
presidents of china and korea are
dancing to entertain the president of
japan they have completely given up on
fighting for equal rights for their
people instead they now dance for the
president in hopes that he will provide
them with food and shelter the waiters
of the bar seem to be planning something
in secret as they hand each other
parcels one of them brings out a gun
from a flush tank that they have
smuggled they take the weapons to the
president's cabin and hold them hostage
soon they take over the entire bar and
hold everyone at gunpoint koga and goto
who were there to get a drink are
shocked the waiters then revealed that
they are actually the north korean
leader and his soldiers who plan to rule
japan the japanese president says that
their defense general is not going to
let that happen since their military is
bigger than north korea's meanwhile
however the defense general is also held
hostage by north korean spies seeing
that he is about to die he detonates an
explosive blowing up the entire building
back at the club the dictator is
celebrating his victory when professor
tato koro appears riding on a kid's
tricycle out of nowhere he tells them
about the tectonic plates yet again
however this time he completes his
sentence and reveals that in only a few
minutes japan is also going to sink
under the sea ending the existence of
mankind right after he finishes a
massive earthquake hits everyone falls
to the ground and starts praying for
their lives people fight with each other
for no reason since everyone is going to
die anyway suddenly the lights go off
the people in the club come together to
light a candle and gather around it in
the background it is narrated that at
least in that last moment world peace
exists
soon another earthquake hits which makes
the land of japan sink under the ocean
at last no humans are left on earth
this is kind of nice
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching